ah good morning ça
va
ah bien dormi ah oui bien sûr comme un
rat normalement je me réveille avec le
soleil mais dès qu'il n'y a pas de
soleil en Bretagne je me réveille pas
c'est ça c'est chez moi depuis 4 ans si
vous voulez voir quand je suis arrivé
ici il pleuvait et je regardais il y
avait une tente brûlée et bon personne
éétait là je je suis monté j'ai
débarrassé le tente boulet j'ai mis ma
tente mais c'était tout dégueulasse ici
tu as l'impression d'être domestiqué si
tu prends un appppartement oui Dom c'est
la
maison c'est j'ai peur j'ai peur de ça
que dès que j'ai le HLM que je vais me
mettre dedans et veillir et ne pas
voyager tant c'est pour ça que je veux
toujours voyager malgré mes mon
rumatisme
salut c'est leilla de brut et
aujourd'hui je me trouve à Rennes et là
et ben je vais descendre parce que on va
partir à la rencontre de Chris HES il a
63 ans c'est un sans abri mais lui il a
trouvé refuge sous un pont du coup je
voulais vraiment partir à sa rencontre
pour un peu comprendre pourquoi il a
décidé de tout quitter pourquoi il est
venu vivre ici pourquoi sous ce pont
coucou Chris bonsoir Comment ça va ça va
découpé bien prépar un feu ouis on va
faire 3 ou 4 degrés bientôt je vais
faire une bon cuisine au dimanche soir
j'entends un petit accent il vient tout
cet accent
ut sal Lake City ut ça fait 30 ans que
je suis en France 32 ans je suis
français
aussi c'est que une palette par soir
parce que je trouve pas beaucoup de
palettes dans ce jourl j'ai trouvé ça
hier dans les rues je l' exporter comme
500 m iciit combien de degrés par moment
ici à Ren oh il faisait moins an hier
matin ah mais ça c'est une stripteas
club maintenant c'est une disco le
stripte club est cassé la figure mais
j'ai demandé permis de faire le muraille
ici mais ça c'est des répliques de
pétroglyph en Uta j'étais mal de pays ça
c'est des aborigines de 10000 ans mon
fils commençait ses études en 2020 et il
voulait pas faire ses études c'est pour
ça que je suis venu pour le pour le le
encourager de continuer ses études je
voulais trouver un appartement avec lui
mais il a déjà signé un contrat avec une
vieille dame juste 300 m
d'ici c'est pour ça que je je suis resté
comme ça et pour lui encourager son
première année de
BTS et fur et à mesure le le premp de
2020 c'était le coronavirus le Lockdown
mais j'avais beaucoup de temps de
aplatir ça de mettre isolation de
trouver des tapis partout dans les rues
de Rennes ça c'est mon fils Gabriel il a
22 ans maintenant ça c'est mon ex quand
elle a commencé son travail comme sage
femme elle avait 24 ans ici mais bon
elle a elle a 60 maintenant c'est ma
fille Juliette qui travaille dans le
cinéma à Paris du coup ton fils il est
il est ici à renes non maintenant il est
à saint-join de Gueré près s mal comment
il voit ta façon de vivre tes enfants
ils sont habitués maintenant ils sont
habitués
oui ma fille n'aime pas parce qu'elle
peut pas visiter et rester elle visite
de temps en temps mais
elle veut pas elle n'aime pas le fumer
dans ses vêtements Orient c'est là la
constellation Orient ça donne ciel il
faut avoir le ciel quand on dort et on
est là on n pas sous le ciel mais quand
même j'aime bien les étoiles ça fait
depuis 2008 que je suis STF le tente est
une
maison c'est pas nécessaire d'avoir un
appartement et surtout quand on voyage
quand on voyage on pas en appartement tu
étais où en j'étais à Paris après le
divorce j'ai donné tout ça à mon
ex-femme toute la maison je voulais pas
diviser les choses je voulais qu'elle a
T les T les affaires pour les enfants et
elle elle est venue en Bretagne j'ai
j'ai pris une année
sabbatique en Australie bon en Amérique
du Sud Australie Nouvelle-Zélande
bermanie et je suis revenu en 2009 avec
20 € mais j'avais mon travail à Paris tu
quoi comme travail j'étais dans Paris
escreté comme prof dans le formation
continue et aussi près de le chan lysé
en école de business et j'ai planté le
tente en 2009 sur un terrain de golf à
tier
7 hectares de terre pour moi entouré par
la ville urbaine de la BAN parisien et
je suis resté 3 ans là-bas pendant que
j'ai continué de donner des cours de
business et tout j'ai fait des feu de
bois et bon ça veut dire que tu étais à
la fois prof en même temps tu vivais
ouais et bon j'étais le prof de les gens
très haut dans la
société pas une question de moyens
finalement tu avais les moyens d'avoir
oui j'avais les moyens mais bon c'est
oui c'était bien de mettre de l'argent à
côté aussi pour mon décrépitude quand je
suis
décrépi quand j'ai 102 ans j'espère que
j'aurais quelques milliers d'euros dans
la banque pour acheter une Yar
quelque
chose non c'était je'ai je n'avais pas
besoin d'un appartement ah j'entend r
C'est quoi j'entends le rat le rat pass
oui bien sûr il des R
t'inquiète pas t'inquiète il est gentil
il va il va que il va pas te mordre
beaucoup que un petit peu qu j'avais ça
mais le rat a fait ça
c'est le c'est le rat qui a fait ça là
oui au fur et à mesure pour entrer ici
c'est impressionnant que ça ne te fasse
absolument rien c'est moi j'aurais
paniqué panique pas c'est il est grand
comme ça il n'est pas rat de Marseille
et ça c'est Henrietta mon pouo
il y a canard il y a le pou là ça c'est
hrietta et ton canard tu l'
comment le
keyb il est cool les gensvent que tu
habites ici est que bien sû j'ai des
vieux qui arrive quand est-ce que tu
fais ton dernier prochain Bouin je mon
tu as vu mes bouquin tu écr un de PO je
crois regarde ça c'est le sous le P de
ouis parce que tu vois ça c'est le S le
pont ici et je vend ça dans le métro
parisien aussi j'ai publié C livre un
roman qui qui parlait de le terrain de
golf à Paris quand l'American STF à
Paris qui gagnait un prix en Amérique
c'est vrai ouais ma vie et mon
expérience que j'ai fait dans le monde
comme une américain qui n'est pas
vraiment un Américain et en français qui
n'est pas vraiment en français je voyage
le monde et j'ai des choses à donner
avant que je MEUR et sont mes écrits
j'ai parlé de bouddhisme parce que j'ai
beaucoup de bouddhisme j'étais en Asie 5
ans en Chine et au Japon bermanie
Thaïlande j'ai tatouages de le dharma ça
c'est le dharma le chemin de bouddhisme
toutes les disciplines les disciplines
que le bouddhiste fait je visite tous
les de 3 ans ça c'est zen zen le Zen
bouddhisme tout
de je veux refaire ça j'aime pas ça j'ai
fait des mains comme parce que c'est en
Argentine la Cueva de las manos c'est
impressionnant ça c'est une Haiku qui
parle quand quand je suis sous le
cisier mes amis semblent très loin tu
considères que ici c'est ton territoire
mais finalement c'est public c'est
public oui mais ils peuvent venir hier
soir quelqu'un était là il faisait un
feu de bois là c'est public ils peuvent
dormir là mais j'aime pas quand il
vientent dégueulasser l'endoit s'il
respecte l'endroit ça va bonsoir ça va
ils font un filme encore ça va être
mercredi soir sur brout ça c'est mon 5e
6e tente le derniers 10 ans tu sais ce
que j'aiécris parce que j'ai passé cet
été à Scandinavie alors pour les
squatterurs ne déf la tente pissz dans
le Villain chiez sur papier journaux et
mettez dans la poubelle videz la
poubelle en eau c'est simple soyez
respectueuse de chez moi et vous serez
respecté merci
Chris parce que les squatterur vient ici
quand je
pars mais même à Paris cette semaine
j'étais à Paris une semaine il y avait
des gens ici qui faisaent des feux de
bois et laissait leur canettes quelques
canettes pas beaucoup mais bon
c'était pas c'était que une semaine que
je suis parti parce que tu vois mon
petit plantation des Iris qui sont oui
les irises sont en train de pousser
maintenant tu V avoir un petit jardin
oui les derniers 3 ans j'avais un jardin
là mais le premier été les squatters ont
détruit le jardin je veux pas dire de
mal de eux mais ils font presque rien
que picoler et de faire la manche et les
gens sont tellement généreux à Ren qu'on
peut faire la manche je fais pas la
manche je reçois le RS ça et j'ai de
l'argent dans la banque parce que j'ai
bossé à Paris et j'ai mis de l'argent à
côté mais les gens reçoi le RSA le 5 de
mois et on peut entendre leur fit parce
qu'il achète les drogues les cocaïne le
hroï toi tu es pas du tout là-dedans non
j'ai foué des joints de temps en temps
mais j'ai 63 ans et je dois faire
attention je veux vivre voir mes petits
enfants tu Allou
ah fire ah Fire et après tu mets ça
hop la nuit non non quand dans tente et
dans deux sacs de couchage je met deux
sacs de couchage pas que une et avec le
bouilloir comme
copine un
oreiller un petit chanson de de l good
night je dore
haché
vegéal je je suis pas végétarien mais
bon champignon fais les courses à côté
de chez toi ah ça c'est donné par
l'association mais Voon je peux il y a
un super rue par là du
riz poireau ah oui
pent ah oui j'adore ça donne des poils
sur
poitrineé on a des fois une douzaine de
personnes ici des grands barbecue
comment il réagissent les gens quand il
deù tu ah je ne sais pas qu ce qu'il
pens sils savent je sais pas pour dire
la vérité les gens me trouve très
spécial ici et bon les gens qui me
connaissent ça va mais quand même je je
ne suis pas normal selon eux je suis pas
normal de
tout pas normal ah non je suis très
anormal je trouve en France il faut être
comme les autres ça c'est le but de la
société un peu mais je sais que c'est
c'est très c'est une pays très libéral
et très bien c'est j'aime j'aime France
mais en même temps il faut s'habituer de
d'être comme les autres sinon tu seras
un peu mise à l'écart mise à
l'écart
j'ai des amis dans le monde le problème
c'est ils sont très loin mon meilleur
ami est en Espagne j'ai des bons amis en
Hongrie toujours et au Japon et en Chine
parce que j'ai voyagé moitié de ma vie
j'étais en voyage sur la planète j'étais
jamais domestiqué je cherche du l'au
puzzle parce qu'il y a une douche ici
douche social
comment 5 minutes à pied ici c'est làb
tu vas te laver ou je peux faire ma
lessive là-bas parce que je bois pas le
Lau de la Villain je fais la vaisselle
avec je fais la vaisselle avec tu fais
la vaisselle dans l'eau de la Villain
ouais mais je le bouie et je mets la
lessive comment s'appelle le détergent
et ça va je suis pas tombé malade et tu
as envie d'avoir un travail comme tu
avais quand tu professeur ah mais quand
j'étais à Paris je bossais les deux
travails à l'école de business et à
l'université j'ai travaillé pendant 20
ans comme une dingue et maintenant je
vois que avec le RS ça et de vivant
comme ça j'ai pas besoin de travailler
mais j'ai 63 ans je sais que en 64 je
dois aller à la retraite je veux
retrouver l'amour c'est ça ma problème
je dois retrouver l'amour de ne pas être
seul dans ma
vie et en vivant comme ça je sais que je
vais rester seul tu as gagné plein
d'argent au cours de ta vie si tu le
mets de côté tu utilises pas tu vas en
faire quoi cet argent c'est ça ser va
pour mes enfants ça fait 3 ans que tu
inscrit pour avoir un HLM ouais ouais
et ok dès que j'ai un HLM je peux
inviter le le gentille jolie fille de
dîner avec moi et peut-être trouver
l'amour encore you understand j'en ai un
peu marre ça fait longtemps ça fait 15
ans que je suis STF j'ai de arthrite
arthrite dans une anche là mais
justement le fait parce que tu as 63 ans
il faut qu'il suive c'est c'est
difficile pour toi de de vivre dans ces
conditions de dormir dans la tente ça
oui oui de plus en plus de crép
ouais c'est difficile c'est pour ça que
je j'ai hâte d'avoir le HLM et et ça
sera bien quand j'ai la HLM là tu fais
quoi de tes journées ici je reste pas
ici je vais dans le le champ libre je
vais dans le champ libre le grand
bibliothèque je travaille sur
l'ordinateur et je lis les les bambou
bouquin je lis les journaux et je
cherche la musique parce que on peut
écouter la musique là avec des earphones
j'écoute la bonne musique où est ma
bière
là je veux améliorer la situation des
sans abris parce que les sans abris en
Amérique non ça je peux pas faire ça je
vais pas faire ça en Amérique ça c'est
vraiment sauvage et ici ça devient de
plus en plus comme à l'Amérique
[Musique]
oh
oh Bab don't
go land of California to SWE home
[Applaudissements]
Chicago bye